going to win
and Kerry Wood
if it wasn't that particular time of my
life where I was shifting and shuffling
the so-called inner deck you know with
what with the way I was with my family
situation being you know I chances are
very slim that I would even got into
this business to be honest with you I i
never had that aspiration as a kid and I
never knew I was an artist I struggled
with it a matter of fact in the business
as successful as I was I mean I've done
40 45 50 TV spots as guests and I was a
regular occurring on thing and even with
that success my art I you know I'm from
the neighborhood I'm kind of a street
guy grew up on the streets of city of
New York and I I just didn't see clearly
enough the art the artist in me until I
did my television show I produced a TV
show called mama and son and in that and
it's quite interesting because it was so
magical for me